sneem snow because I saw snow for the
first time in my life here in Germany
guns guns that were a long long time ago
almost 15 years ago here in Germany
there's only snow chaos but in India
there's every other kind of chaos that's
my house where I live
I built it two years ago spy on about
Anand Narayana Swamy has made it in
Germany he has his own house and a
well-paying job which means instead I'm
a Sales Director for Tech Mahindra
India's biggest IT company for
telecommunications solutions Europe
telecommunications losing him let's - is
the key to my office
or maybe not as he works and and often
switches between speaking English German
Hindi or Tamil it was this prog thing
which we went for they called us for
another meeting again right shut what is
that feel killing I really learned a
great deal here people are very
meticulous very very punctual and the
Germans are really straightforward it's
different in India people say one thing
and do another the lifestyle is
completely different
Nan's job requires him to travel a lot
during the Christmas holidays he takes
his wife and children back home to India
Chennai is the capital of Tamilnadu the
11th largest state in India it's located
on the Gulf of Bengal in the south of
the country
Indian India is just the way it's
advertised incredible India there is a
lot of poverty a lot of development lots
of culture and a great deal of chaos
it's everything all at once mix together
I live a fine model image that makes it
very difficult to describe in just a few
words it's an experience does the
standard lateness until 1969 Chennai was
known as Madras some five million people
live here and the population is
exploding
a nun's parents live in an apartment in
one of the city's quieter areas yo I'm
staying up here on the third floor
beginning in science so now let's go in
to see my father
Ryu Narayana Swamy this is where I spend
my time when I come to India on vacation
beneath some wall of not Indian comment
this is my father Raju my mother Vijaya
my grandmother her name is Manoj and
somebody very special is also here the
newest addition to the family
shreya he's come from America where he's
already a citizen Aruna my sister is a
structural engineer the whole family's
here even my sister Anu she's a doctor
lives in England I was England all kind
of estefania then he shows us a place
that's special to him
that's this fine evening this used to be
my favorite place when I was still very
young when I was in 11th and 12th grade
before a big exam I'd come up here sit
down and study I was him I here and
Gazette you nobody could bother me up
here Chad on Y&Z with the feeling yeah
it felt wonderful how about the others
but the view was different back then now
so many tall buildings are going up all
around it's unbelievable
these days Anand goes up on the roof to
do his pranayama exercises when I am on
the [ __ ] pranayama works something
like this you inhale through one nostril
and exhale out the other but there's a
gap in between scenes ik inhale for 10
seconds wait 5 seconds then exhale for
10 seconds a lot
that's it that gives me clear air to
breathe and it helps me to concentrate
so constantly and I said Annabelle it
does something for mine that basil it's
good for developing discipline and these
are discipline on visa discipline and
concentration are both useful to my
career in mine Vanek Arrieta
that's the salute salute it's coming off
Medina man you can also recite verses
while doing the exercises for example I
repeat this verse when I practice
pranayama than 10 times in the morning
10 times an evening Oh wah Oh wah I'm
gonna hand warmed up on her own zip down
Oh mapa Jody does a humdrum ma boo boo a
su at all so much bless the right way to
do it according to our Brahmin tradition
brahmana to the ceiling the Brahmins
were once the highest caste
traditionally made up of teachers
scholars and priests they strive for
purity integrity and compassion for all
forms of life we all know him we also
have a family all true my father and
mother the entire family right there
every day wouldn't my no Matta here in
India every family has an alternate ah
here in India the next day
Anand and his family set out on a
pilgrimage yeah
if I'm get snuff swabbing my night the
system we're going to Swami Maulana
that's our family temple our family God
my parents and in-laws go there every
year
Edith yeah they leave overcrowded
Chennai and traveled 280 kilometers deep
into the interior of Tamil Nadu
being incredible isn't it it's really
unbelievable incredible India
is once everything that is of use is
holy to us does these died you see the
image of God the driver has applied to
his windshield better yeah wind should
shave a gimmick oh yeah he believes his
cab feeds him every day that's here
appearance his daily bread with this car
the sign essence they didn't have on
this thing for these Amato hunger is
still an issue even in upwardly mobile
India about a quarter of the population
is still too poor to feed themselves
this is puducherry on the bay of bengal
it's lunchtime at a seafood restaurant
the Narayana Swamy family still eats a
strictly vegetarian meal Brahman Hindus
are expected to abstain from eating
animals who do you get them again
yes anagh Legia we're all eating from
banana leaves here but I'm they're very
clean and here they're very carefully
prepared he has all buddy mocked
there aren't any insects nothing missing
and after the meal the leaves are not
thrown away they're fed two counts so
they get something to eat
- and that's direct biodegradation
biodegradation there was no time left to
go to the beach they still have 100
kilometers left to travel
that's what
in the late afternoon they arrived in
sir Kali
this is where a man's wife Priya's
parents live their grandson Shravan
hasn't been here in over two years he
was born in Frankfurt and is having a
bit of trouble recognizing all of the
berries family members he's great uncle
for example he told us to take off our
shoes shoes are always removed before
entering a traditional Indian household
he did not to test
Shaban and his sister sweater think
their grandparents house is a
fascinating place
they're behind you back there the tree
goes from up there all the way down to
the house that's you put this here and
then we grind spices on from the other
than this oh that way it's really fresh
masala and other spices papa
he's got a spider on his foot not as
long as it's not a snake subtropical
animal life isn't exactly sweaters cup
of tea with plants it's different
you
the next morning they arrived in Swami
malai a sacred temple it's an important
pilgrimage destination for Tamil Hindus
as a savage distance and this is very
important the ashes are sacred
we are cremated after we die and when
we're cremated our bodies become ashes
then we have a grunts end when the asha
it's a philosophy when we put it on our
faces and look in the mirror then we
know that will return to ashes in the
end so we saw a ship Adhan and that's
fine we always wear it it's not just
face painting that you see on the people
here we put a lot of ash on our
foreheads we're doing it for the earth
our fellow humans made not just for
ourselves let's tune on this pure one's
life
come on ERISA you just got I should
really come here every year but now that
I've been living in Germany for some
time it's not really possible to come
here every time I come to India this
Marvin is my Indian call me at Sepang
thing has to be done is to go to the
elephant board
prayed to him saying that blesses to do
all our prayers properly
the main temple isn't dedicated to the
widely worshipped elephant god Ganesha
the Tamils here pray to the beloved
Murugan the sister lot route is Lord
Muruga
he's Ganesh's little brother Ganesha is
the elephant God and Lord Murugan is our
family God needy and I'm gonna be
elevated amar are you
sorry okay okay oh yeah okay turn the
camera off Oh Nelson I feel really
really good because we come back here
after so many years I had to be with my
wife my children's I'm in my parents and
in-laws everyone together yeah Anton
Schwieger
Alton alle this is a very very important
day for me
Vista top finish - after the visit to
the temple it's time for a small
refreshment Wow
so please great pickup following the
short break they're on their way again
the drive back to Chennai takes about
eight hours and passes through rural
areas
and asks these women what they're
growing here
you
back in Chennai
Anand wants to visit the elite school
where he learned the basics for the
career he's chosen but the school is
closed for the holidays an and knows a
shortcut to the playing field behind the
school fun a lot since the school was
closed in the front here we are in the
back yeah this is where I used to play
cricket cricket is India's most popular
sport good event when the record is also
called the gentlemen's game or a noble
game I tried to avoid getting hurt and I
was afraid to bat that's why I was
always a colorful batting gap and vivid
what is mine baller the bowler is the
one who bowls or throws the ball to the
opposing batsman in visa to Lecompton it
takes more than money to get into this
school it's totally performance oriented
I was just one of 3,000 students who
applied to go to school here there are
still many things that are special about
this school we were taught the Vedas why
give up it's called a Diana and Anglo
Vedic or DAV suck Munsu this is for the
DAV on tangley it follows the English
system but Veda is always included to
fit into NN we were given spiritual
instruction with yoga meditation and the
rest
I believe that's had an effect on our
concentration and success as individuals
ones that untie and fall and for has
mentioned
once again a mix of tradition and
modernity that is typical for India and
foreign hands life as well Indian
Whitesburg India and Germany or Europe
well they're only comparable to a point
yes we're a large democracy but there
are also a handful of political families
think they can simply pass power down to
their children you know MOT Gavin Kenton
on the wife and that bothers me
I need a Kingdom on the stet mistake
they manipulate the entire electoral
system and there's a lot of corruption
because they simply want to manipulate
the voters I'm father manipulation
Indian politics is also a topic of
discussion in the evening Anand is
meeting up with his friend Rakesh whom
he's known for over 20 years unlike an
and rock has decided to pursue a career
in India he is super stockist I think
for Microsoft trade we are not raised or
raised partner for Microsoft Adobe core
LM Symantec most of the leading software
vendors yes Anand and Rakesh represent
India's new well educated middle class
they're not happy about how the
political system works travela become
become some things that's my question
why can't an RN become something are you
willing to spend that money for
campaigning are you going ready to
invest now why can't the Gandhi family
in Western someone else that's my
question why will they then on here for
charity so politics is business but
they're not
there's a lucrative business very
resolutely the two friends haven't got
much time
Anand plans to set out on a 1700
kilometer long trip into the past the
following morning
this is Kolkata which used to be called
Calcutta in the federal state of West
Bengal Anand was born here in 1973 as
the child of one could say migrants
within India this is where he spent the
first five years of his life his cousin
Ango is a tea merchant he's also one of
the last family members still living
here
he is invoked and this is the red road
back when the British were here the
Indians were not allowed to walk in this
street at all those were the days of
apartheid in India but hindsight India
was a British colony until 1947 the
Queen Victoria Memorial left over from
the colonial days is still very popular
today have you ever taken me inside when
I was a kid no I don't think so you must
have gone on your own but I've not taken
do you want to go and say oh no look at
the flower heads so big it'll take hours
you think I will make it in 20 30
minutes no I think it's it's too big
Ann Ann doesn't want to waste time
standing in line to get into the museum
he'd rather look for a shop that he
remembers from his childhood
nothing has changed here in the last 30
years
the shop serves Annan's favorite kind of
yogurt and it's the only place where it
tastes just like it did three decades
ago
he returns to the house where he lived
until he was five years old it's all
changed
and this is the house actually yeah I
used to spend a lot of time here I
always played cricket and I ran around a
lot so he won't get poked I dig it
there are people here who still remember
an ant and his family
of Indian hollow they own the buildings
and they rent the whole thing out it's
amazing to be here again after 30 years
Raisa John in the back courtyard he has
another go at cricket just like in the
old days
thanks good thanks if there's not enough
room here for a big guy like me so
behind grows on one wish that evening he
returns to Chennai
we are so rich yet so poor that's how I
would want to really put it in one
sentence about in here there is a guy
sleeping on the road what what has what
what have they done for these guys
whereas I just put it in contrast
straight with Germany you know you
cannot find this there are poor people
in Germany as well but they are taken
care of by the governor asking in
Germany is politics also a family
business it is not at all II never it
does stuff it's it's a super democracy
and if you if you've seen the Chancellor
of Germany dr. Angela Merkel she is
actually from the eastern part of
Germany
she has been democratically voted into
power the last stop on Ananse trip home
is mahabalipuram which has a seaside
temple
it's a UNESCO World Cultural Heritage
Site
wobbly Brahmin mahabalipuram is a
wonderful example of ancient Tamil
culture it was built between the 6th and
8th centuries
let's go so temple if this is the shore
temple it is truly unique
it's nearly 1,400 years old and is still
in good condition and beautiful campus
to grab that's why it's a world cultural
heritage site but I do find it a bit
peculiar that kids can run around like
that on a monument to global culture
forever this is the last time Anand will
visit his homeland as an Indian citizen
he has since acquired a German passport
it's hubba anglish by this I've lived in
both cultures and I understand them both
on Donder that's made me a more tolerant
person and also more discipline yeah
that's because I still follow my Indian
traditions but I now live in Germany
where discipline really matters I let's
get on and that's how the powerful
effect on me on this bit not the end you
know what I think about India maybe some
things are not done there as well as
they are in German Achtung but India is
unique a completely different world
things could still really take off there
if not right now then in a few years
when this gets flashing high on
my mama
you
time
birthday